all right the Democratic resistance is
running at full tilt making threats um
launching investigations of 81 people
and enterprises associated and some of
not even associated with President Trump
now naturally the House Judiciary
Committee Chairman Democrat Jerry Nadler
is out bloviating for the president's
impeachment do you think the president
structure justice yes I do
it's very clear that the president
struck the justice it's very clear 1,100
times he referred to the mole
investigation as a witch-hunt he tried
to be fired he tried to protect the
Flynn from being investigated by the by
the FBI he fired Comey in order to stop
the Russian thing as he told NBC News
okay so now giving one's opinion
qualifies as obstruction of justice now
I don't know what federal criminal law
and Adler studied but my legal
background says that is just ludicrous
now contrary to what Nadler and company
claimed none of this is about exercising
their constitutional right to oversight
of the executive branch I want you to
understand that it's not about what they
say it's about so document request who
needs documents why your testimony
they've already made up their minds
Muller by the way has spent two years
investigating Russia's possible
collusion in the 2016 an election and it
looks like he's come up with nothing
he's issued indictments called witnesses
before the grand jury he's interviewed
more than 40 people he's reviewed over a
million documents and he's even referred
separate matters to the Southern
District of New York and remember the
Democrats glowing words about Muller
when he was appointed this is an
absolutely brilliant choice there is no
more respected figure in American law
enforcement than Bob Muller I think the
best thing that happened with was to
have something like Muller to come in
he's the pro he's gonna follow the facts
where they leak okay ha then then why
didn't have ler not trust him and his
prosecutors who've already by the way I
just found this out spent 25
million dollars of the taxpayer money on
this investigation why did they trust
him then to get to the bottom of things
he was the greatest thing since sliced
bread even Ty Cobb says so now now the
way I see Nadler will come on he away I
said now there's going to almost
entirely retail the ground that Muller
has already passed over but why is
Nadler doing this getting back to our
theme of unmasking for the sole purpose
of creating a political spectacle and to
continue it right up until the last vote
is counted in 2020 remember President
Nixon was threatened with impeachment
for obstruction of justice President
Clinton was impeached for obstruction of
justice so why is NaN third not moving
forward with the articles of impeachment
against President Trump immediately
impeachment is a long way down the road
we don't we don't have the facts yet but
we're going to initiate a proper
investigation you do not now have the
evidence all sorted out and everything
to to doing it to to do an impeachment
before you impeach somebody you have to
persuade the American public that it
ought to happen actually that's not in
the Constitution either but whatever
that's the Constitution but a separate
question isn't that what Nadler has been
trying to do with his recent impeachment
media tour he's been trying to convince
the public that there are a thousand
reasons to impeach the president even if
he cannot prove a single one meanwhile
the House Ways and Means Committee Chair
Richard Neal is requesting the
president's tax returns from the IRS
that's a shock applause e spokesman says
they will take all necessary steps
including litigation if necessary to
obtain them what does that have to do
with collusion well anyway all of this
sends a thrill up the leg of the media
resistance of course yesterday the New
York Times editorial page tantalized its
readers by predicting a long and painful
ordeal for the president and those close
to him quote political investigations
tend to be marathons rather than
Sprint's with his investigation mr.
Nadler is looking to build a case for
impeachment
so compelling it will have enough
bipartisan support to survive the
republican-controlled Senate
barring that his investigation will
serve to keep the heat on mr. Trump and
perhaps keep the Democratic base at
least somewhat placated as the next
election of roses aha well at least they
admit that this is an entirely
politically motivated attack meant to
soften up the president for 2020 and
dangle some red meat on a hook for their
base now note the wishful thinking I
love that line on the editorial thinking
of bipartisan support for impeachment
hmm well could you count that out
completely well at a time when
Republicans should be bolstering the
President's agenda
I'm key issues especially I see on one
at least they're undermining him and
leadership can't seem to hold it
together
hoping the president would not take the
national emergency route hmm I want you
to decide to do that I said I would
support it but I was hoping he wouldn't
take that particular path well that's a
really bold statement I was supporting
it hoping he wouldn't take it meaning
he's not going to insist that his
members put the real pressure as he
could do on his members actually push
you know look with all due respect it is
partly Mitch McConnell's fault that the
president had to declare a national
emergency at all he and Paul Ryan
promised the president when he signed
that ridiculous omnibus spending bill
last year that they would get him the
funding he needed for the wall before
last year ended no matter what happened
in the election well what happened well
we predicted on this show they didn't do
it McConnell has done a masterful job of
getting judges through the Senate
phenomenal on the court Supreme Court
stuff all of that and I he can't control
how Collins Markowski people like Rand
Paul vote but he basically signaled to
them that their vote against the
President on this issue of the national
emergency was okay
my friends Congress specifically
delegated
the president the authority to declare
national emergencies they did it long
ago in sections 201 and 301 of the
national emergencies act if you're a law
geek it's 50 USC 1601 he cited this in
his official declaration the president
did as is required and the president has
already invoked his national emergency
powers on three occasions adding to the
28 earlier national emergency measures
that remain in effect today this is an
important point Congress has never
before moved to end a president's
emergency declaration until now now even
the New York Times front page today
painted a grim picture of what's
happening at the border here's a quote a
feverish teenager with a vile smelling
wound on his foot a man with a head
injury and a bright red eyes children
with fevers coughs and colds and the
Customs and Border Patrol numbers of
family units crossing the border was
breathtaking we have apprehended and
encountered more families in just five
months and five days than last year's
records hold now 70% of all crossings
are from these countries and a full 62
percent of all crossings and encounters
are vulnerable families and children
we've had almost 2,400 fraudulent claims
families now more on the dire situation
of the border is going to be coming up
later in the show you do not want to
miss it it goes way beyond that and
there's a lot more in that New York
Times piece we're gonna get into and we
will be naming names and unmasking the
motives of those on the left and some on
the right who are working to stop
stronger enforcement our southern border
which includes a physical barrier the
president must continue to stand firm on
this issue and forge ahead against the
Chamber of Commerce Republicans who want
an endless flow of cheap flavor and the
open borders Democrats who think they
have an endless supply of new voters and
as for the Democratic impeachment squad
keep on masking the real motives you bet
if they cared about the Constitution and
the rule of law they wouldn't have let
the border get this out
control in the first place and they
would have demanded that Hillary Clinton
and her Protectorate pay for their
wrongdoing that's law and order don't
you think this is a political war all of
this that you're saying around you and
it's meant to undo the president's
successes and block his agenda for the
next two years that's all it's about
this isn't just harassment of President
Trump he said that today it's harassment
of the millions of Americans who voted
for his agenda and it's an abuse of the
entire democratic process that the
Democrats claimed to care so much about
and that's the angle